so gehe ich übrigens auch immer auf
meiner wohnung raus also wenn der eigene
wand im weg ist oder so dann nutze ich
nicht die tür oder sowie ein weg oder
läufer wieder zurück euer lieblings und
bester fordert spieler ich habe vor
einigen tagen bereits fordert auf einem
kanal hochgeladen
[Musik]
ja das lief nicht so gut allerdings habt
ihr mir dann ganz ganz viele tipps in
die kommentare geschrieben die ich
besser werden kann in vor neid und der
tipp der meisten geschrieben wurde war
luca wenn du alleine spielst dann
spielen nicht auf modus team sondern
ändert denen auf solo ja da hätte ich
auch selbst drauf kommen können
[Musik]
was geht denn hier ab ein weiterer tipp
der mir ebenfalls oft geschrieben wurde
war luca wenn du in diesem bus hier bist
wo man runter springen muss mit
leertaste die meisten hier springen
einfach schon wieder runter springer
besten irgendwo runter wo jetzt nicht
irgendwie wald ist sondern wo man
irgendwie ein bisschen blut kriegen kann
das heißt ich bringe jetzt einfach mal
runter und versuche jetzt so ein
bisschen hier mit den pfeiltasten
eventuell da vorne hinzukommen so ganz
nah dran und jetzt geht der falschen
automatisch auf genau und da oh mein
gott wie so landen hier dann schon
wieder verlassen jetzt einfach mal hier
vorne genau und jetzt sehen wir hier
schon die ganzen fahrzeuge und kisten
ich kenne die website nicht ich weiß
nicht wo hier irgendwas ist hier ist
nichts drin
dann laufen wir mal hier vorne lang
mache ich mal hier eben die tür auf hier
ist nun die garage haben wir auch eine
schadensfalle dann haben wir das ding
will ich mein ich wollte euch nur zeigen
wie man es nicht machen sollte
ich habe wieder keinen plan was hier
gerade abgeht ich werde jetzt mal
probieren nicht über seiner fetten stadt
wie zb da vorne raus zu springen sondern
jetzt vielleicht einfach jetzt hier
vorne schon und dann da vorne irgendwie
hin zu geben es könnte sein dass sich
mit einer der ersten gerade in dieser
stadt hier bin deswegen dreht hier vorne
mal eben eine ganz kurze runde um dann
hier vorne zu landen fakt dass noch mehr
spieler also hier vorne haben wir eine
waffe und munition das heißt die wechsel
jetzt direkt bei auf die waffe ist
könnte sein dass ich jetzt direkt schon
einen kill mache freunde
oh mein gott jetzt habe ich wirklich
jemand die nominiert im letzten video
meinten einige leute hey luca du hast
diese person gar nicht getötet wo du
dachtest du hast sie getötet das war nur
weil der sturm da war und du hast du ein
bisschen angeschossen bevor kink er ihr
habt alle keine ahnung ich bin der beste
fortnight spieler zu deinem herzen match
für 200 kirche wird fünf jahre gewählte
presse alter ich habe meine sachen
müssen eingesammelt er mit schauen wir
mal hier draußen da vorne sogar spieler
dürfen wir natürlich einfach mal direkt
wieder jemanden dominiert ich meine
freunde ist juckt mich nicht ich bin
halt einfach der beste fortnight spieler
so da kann man auch nichts machen da
kann man nicht meckern wenn da
irgendwelche anderen komischen timing
youtuber ankommen alt habe die durch
vergraben contractor ja dass der schritt
jetzt gehe ich erstmal verdammten
baumfällen alter also ich habe jetzt
das
von mir und das war geplant weil der ich
muss ich muss gleich los die türe öffnet
sich jetzt hier in drei sekunden das
heißt spam schon die leertaste und sagt
sich diesmal wirklich als allererste
rausspringen das haben sich zum glück
kein anderer hier gedacht da vorne
fliegen paar hin hier vorne
ich werde es allerdings probieren da
vorne mal hin zu gelangen mir wurde
unter anderem auch als tipp in die
kommentare geschrieben dass es
verschiedene arten von waffen gibt es
gibt bronze das ist dass sie zb die ist
relativ scheiße glaube ich dann gibt es
halt aber noch andere mein gott du weg
sei was fällt ihnen ein freunde dass ich
meine ihr habt den titel gesehen ich bin
bester fordert spieler
das liegt aber jetzt gerade ein bisschen
daran dass ich die zweite hand gerade
noch an meinem handy hat und neben einer
und andere spiele gespielt habe deswegen
komme jetzt gehe ich mal mit beiden
händen an die tastatur hier wurde auf
jeden fall gesagt es gibt verschiedene
farben bei den waffen beziehungsweise
verschiedene stufen sage ich mal
es gibt einmal grau dass es gewöhnlich
grün ist irgendwie ungewöhnlich und dann
gibt es noch so lila und gold und
legendär und irgendwie so weit ich habe
mich ja letztens schon total gefreut
wenn ich irgendwelche grünen sachen
hatte oder irgendwie so arbeitet sind
halt wirklich einfach nur ungewöhnliche
sachen also jetzt werde ich mal hier
vorne einfach versuchen direkt zu landen
jetzt muss sie wieder kaputt machen wir
haben eine pumpgun das ist allerdings
eine gewöhnliche waffe also dies jetzt
nicht sonderlich gut aber ich bin jetzt
halt auch nicht über irgendeine stadt
abgesprungen hier ist die kiste die
durch suche ich jetzt einfach mal hier
ist ein sturmgewehr es hier immer noch
ein paar andere sachen nein ich bin aber
ich habe ein bisschen angst dass andere
leute kommen ich habe das gefühl da
versteckt sich ein dahinter
warum hey ich will youtube ich will
jetzt video drehen
das ich hab' ich war ich habe meine
brille nicht auf ein paar sekunden
später
ich hab so wie gerade wieder gefunden
diesmal ist das kleine da vorne mein
ziel also ich mache jetzt direkt man
schon den falschen haufen versucht jetzt
da irgendwo hinzufliegen die scheiße ist
das hier unten auch schon welche
versuchen da hinzugehen und auch direkt
perfekt landen deswegen stehe ich jetzt
einfach ein stückchen weiter hier hin
weil ich angst habe dass ich direkt
wieder getötet werde als ich meinen
eigentlich habe ich keine angst die
leute sollten angst vor mir haben weil
ich bin halt der beste spieler und hier
drinnen haben wir direkt eine ganz
gewöhnliche waffe also ein richtiges
waffe was haben wir hier vorne haben wir
auch eine stinknormale gewöhnliche waffe
haben jetzt noch mal hier vorne hoch
haben wir hier noch was hier ist nichts
außer ein bisschen munition das gebäude
sieht so ähnlich aus wie das was sich in
der ersten folge entdeckt hat ist das
jetzt eine kiste
weil wenn der letzten folge meinten so
leute zu mir würde oder kippte vorbei
ich habe hier meine gewöhnlichen waffen
und kommen damit auch mega gut zurecht
meine taktik ist so ein bisschen mehr
dass ich mich hier so ein bisschen
anschleichen von der seite mal so ein
bisschen das ganze geschehen hier
beobachte und dann fällig hier einen
baum
hallo ich bin da diese treffe hier hat
irgendwer gebaut
das heißt wir schauen mal ob es sich
hier noch drin befindet ich denke er
nicht
weil sonst hätte er uns schon getötet
und hätten wir ihn schon getötet laufen
bei jemandem triple lange hier ist auch
niemand hier sind ein paar bettchen also
wir haben gerade noch leute geschlafen
eventuell kann man hier vorne rum laufen
wir noch ein paar waffen die die leute
haben liegen lassen das
ihre freunde so macht man das nämlich
also ich habe jetzt gerade wirklich
meine erste epische waffe gefunden
nämlich kann euch mal zeigen dass das
sind bad fliesen noch guck mal freund
jetzt wenn wir hier sogar noch eine
epische waffe die meinen rucksack ist
voll
die mach ich denn den rucksack auf so
gehe ich übrigens auch immer aus meiner
wohnung raus also wenn er irgendwann tim
weg ist oder so dann nutze ich nicht die
tür oder suchen den weg oder ich hatte
halt die beiden epischen waffen so und
das ding ist so ich meine ich will euch
hat zeigen dass ich der beste spieler
bin und da geb ich halt den anderen dann
lieber die epischen lassen ich hab das
ja auch mit gewöhnlichen waffen die hier
vorne will ja anscheinend auch landen
aber wir sind natürlich hier vorne
direkt und ich glaube ich ist sogar eine
grüne manöver bekomme ich denn nieder
richtig hin wir haben noch was blau ist
also etwas seltenes das heißt die nehme
ich jetzt auf jeden fall mal und jetzt
mal schauen wo die kollegen hier
gelandet ist okay hier ist niemand
dann nehmen wir hier nochmal ein
bisschen verband mit wo wir die den
brauch ich nicht weil ich sterbe hier
vorne ist noch eine grüne waffe die
nehme ich auch mal eben mit das ist
irgendwie taktische scheiße oder
irgendwie so genau so heiß dass nämlich
also man kann sich hier unten auf jeden
fall verlaufen das liegt im rahmen des
möglichen
es sind schon 30 spieler gestorben sich
gerade anscheinend weggelaufen weil sie
angst hatte das komplette web design und
die komplette grafik ist halt so team
fortress mäßig und ich feiere das
einfach enorm also wie das hier alles
aussieht und allein dass man alles
irgendwie abbauen kann und so irgendwie
ist hier weit und breit kein mensch zu
sehen aber meine damen und herren bauen
ist natürlich auch ein großer
bestandteil des spielprinzips von
fordert deswegen würde ich sagen baue
ich mir doch jetzt mal ein haus eine
ewigkeit später also das hier ist jetzt
das haus was ich gerade errichtet habe
hier eine ganz kurze vum tour hier vorne
ist mein wohnbereich hier ist mein
essensbereich hier schlafe ich und jetzt
eine treppe kann man hoch gehen habe ich
auch eine wundervoll aussicht über die
ganze stadt
wir sehen weit und breit keine nachbarn
vorhanden
frag mich wenn ich jetzt hier runter
gehe ob ich dann fallschirm irgendwie
ach nee sie ist einfach runter eastman
house
ich dachte was ihn gebaut entschuldigung
herr kommissar darf sich über die brücke
gehen nur wenn sie was aus dem lukas
abkaufen ja ok perfekt mache ich hier
vorn haben wir noch so eine normale
waffe was haben wir hier vorne drin hier
ist gar nicht mülltonne ist können wir
neues zuhause werden wo freuen ich habe
hier vorne hat eine kiste gefunden
seltene sache für mich sind seltene
sachen mittlerweile einfach nichts
besonderes mehr also ich glaube ich
jetzt mal hier in den fluss manchmal
meine inventar offen verband kann ich
mal wegschmeißen brauche ich nicht die
waffe brauche ich auch nicht die
gewöhnlich waffe zweimal benötige ich
auch nicht dann wäre ich jetzt meine
freundin jagdgewehr nehme ich mir mal
mit hier ein schild tranken
wer braucht denn tränke oder hinten ist
ein spieler wir hatten uns jetzt gerade
so ein teil des battle hier gegeben
ich bin jetzt mal gespannt ob gustav
hoffmann hat laser luca 69 mit dem
gewehr durchlöchert
ich hatte einfach nicht nur ein tag an
der stelle will ich das video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn euch vor neid auf einem
kanal gefällt dann lässt man leichter
und wenn ihr eine neue folge wollt wie
ich euch zeigen wie es geht dann lass
mal 60.000 leister freunde
das ist eine hohe zahl aber letztmals
die 50.000 geschafft singen wenn ihr das
schafft dann lade ich neuen plattform
hoch und sonst würde ich an der stelle
jetzt einfach wirklich nur noch sagen